weekly seminar assignments today we are
very happy to have matt ruderson from
university from michigan
he is going to tell us about the nodal
demands of
gnp graphs go ahead please
thank you very much and thank you for
the opportunity to speak
uh i don't this is based in part on a
joint work with hong kong
formerly from university of michigan now
from georgia tech
and i don't have to introduce jnp graphs
but i have to say what
nodal domains are so this notion comes
from
a geometry and
i assume that m is a compact smooth
manifold
and if we have a laplacian on it we can
consider
an eigen function corresponding to some
eigenvalue
and a nodal domain is just a connected
component of the set
where the eigen function is positive or
negative
and this is a classical object in
geometry
so the standard equations are the
numbers of the number of noble domains
and it depends on k the number of
eigenvalue
and the geometry of those domains
so let's take the most primitive example
our manifold is an interval
and the laplacian is of course the
second derivative
will take directly boundary conditions
and then the eigenfunctions will be
signs so the first eigen function is
always positive we have one nodal domain
the second has two nodal domains
the third three etc
and this is a general picture uh
for uh in general for a manifold the
number of nodal domains
increases regularly and
current proved that the number of nodal
domains
of k-th eigen function of l plus n
doesn't exceed k
and it usually increases a similar
notion can be introduced
for graphs and it was considered
uh first by nigel lineal
so we take a graph and for the graph we
introduce the adjacency matrix putting
ones
where the edges are and zeros otherwise
and then define the laplacian as a
uh laplacian for the manifold
so we sum up the the values of the
function
for all vertices for all neighbors of v
of u sorry and subtract the value at u
itself
multiplied by the degree of it
so it's the adjacency matrix minus
the degree matrix the diagonal matrix
with degrees on the diagonal
and decaly and lineal
really surprising fact that for a graph
unlike for a manifold the number of
nodal domains doesn't grow
it stays uniformly bounded
regardless of the number of the
eigenvalue
and moreover later aurora and baskara
improved it
first by relaxing the assumption that p
is a constant and second
this bound for the number of mole
domains
turned out to be exactly two
of course it's true only for non-leading
eigenva vector the leading eigenvector
has all on only one nodal domain
and then linear put forward the whole
program of studying nodal domains
so to say geography of nodal domains
let's view the positive nodal domain as
earth
the negative as water and then we can
ask all kinds of questions
example what's the distribution of
heights the distances to the shore
was the length of the shoreline etc
and the main tool and studying all these
questions
is the localization of eigenvectors
of random matrices so what is it
let's take a gaussian square random
matrix
either full id or id symmetric
both ensembles are invariant under
rotations
and an eigenvector
being a function of a
distribution of a matrix will be also
invariant on the rotations so it's
uniformly distributed over the sphere
and if we believe in the central limit
phenomenon
a large matrix should behave like a
gaussian one
so for a large matrix
the eigenvector should be approximately
uniformly distributed
this is the delocalization and we can
quantify it
in various ways the most classical one
is their infinitive localization if we
take
a unit vector uniformly distributed over
the sphere
its coordinates are of order one over
square root of n after logarithmic
factor with high probability
and this is true also for a unit
eigenvector
of a large matrix this was proved for
symmetric matrices
by knowles yahweh and yin
and it was proved jointly with russian
for
the matrices with id random entries
so the l infinity the localization rules
out
large coordinates there are no spikes
but there is a complemented
complementary notion
to it we want to rule out also small
coordinates
we want to say there are not many of
those
so there are no gaps in
the support of the eigenvector and this
is
this is supplied by no gaps the
localization
so for any set j
which is sufficiently large this set
supports a non-negligible proportion
of the l2 norm
this is very easy to show for a uniform
vector on the sphere
and it turns out to be true also
for the eigenvectors of
random matrices
and it was proved jointly with virginia
for a very large class of random
matrices including
full id id symmetric i discuss a metric
etc
so if the set of coordinates
is large uh relatively large
then indeed it supports
a non-negligible mass
or
uh and the mass depends only on the
proportion
and actually it's it's true at the same
time
for all sets j of a given
cardinality
six sevens and six are here
definitely suboptimal but we didn't
chase
the optimal bound here and so
one type of the localization rules out
large coordinates another type rules out
small coordinates
and these two work in tandem
to show it let's uh
let's do a very short proof of
uh declaratively lineal or bhaskar
theorem
so let's prove that any
nodal domain sorry any non-leading
eigenvector has only two null domains
we'll do it in two steps
so first let's take the largest positive
nodal domain
and the largest negative normal domain
and then consider
the complement of those
this junk set and our aim is to show
that this junk set is empty
let's take a smaller step for uh
for a moment and let's show that it is
small
actually it is uh about log squared
n and this is just combinatorial
probability 101
we don't need any random matrix theory
for it
first how many components
are in this set w how many normal
domains
two nodal domains of the same type say
two positive normal domains cannot be
connected and
otherwise they will be one nodal domain
and if two sets are not connected then
one of them should be small
over a log n so
all the sets all the nodal domains here
are what are
log n and how many are those
let's consider only positive nodal
domains here
and take one point on vertex from each
nodal domain
they don't connect it so we form an
independent set
and the cardinality of independent
independent set is also
over a log n at most
we have log n independent
log n nodal domains each of those
contains
at most login elements
so we have a total of log squared
why can you make the second assertion is
it probabilistic
yeah this is also elementary probability
you'll just calculate i mean
that a given set of vertices
is independent and user union bound
i meant actually the first bullet point
uh the same you just assumed that there
is uh there are two large
uh not connected sets
and evaluate this probability then take
a union bound
[Music]
so this is all elementary this doesn't
require
any random matrix theory
next so we got this and for simplicity
i'll assume
that p is constant in order not to carry
it through the
the argument and then the giant set
is of the logarithmic order polylog
order
okay assume that it's not empty
take a vertex in it and suppose that the
coordinate corresponding to this vertex
is negative
then this vertex cannot be connected to
negative normal domain
because otherwise it would be absorbed
there
and then i'll write what uh the fact
that
x is an eigenvector means and i'll read
only
one row of this equality of the row
corresponding to w
so lambda times x w is the w
coordinate of this product so what is
this product
it's the sum of coordinates of
all neighbors of w
and the numbers can be in the positives
don't know the mean
or they can be in the junk set they
cannot be in the negative nodal domain
as we saw a moment ago
but this allows me to estimate the first
term in this election in this equality
it is bounded by the absolute value of w
times the maximal coordinate plus the
the second term which i can bound to in
a similar way
i take the number of terms and
multiplied by the maximum coordinate
so what do we have since it's an
unliving eigenvector
lambda is at most square root of n
this is very small it's poly log order
and we have l infinity the localization
this l infinity norm is only log
over square root of n square root of n
cancels
i get a polylog
and if i know the sum i can estimate the
second
uh vel to norm delta norm is bounded by
uh the sum of the squares is bounded
that by the sum
times the maximal coordinate and again i
use
the infinitive localization this sum is
only log this is poly log
over square root of n i got
poly log divided by the square root of n
find by this would contradict the null
gaps of localization because
this set on which i am
estimating the l to norm is
large and large means
proportional to n
may ask how do you know that the leading
eigenvalue is
bounded by square root of n and also how
do you know that there is at least two
domains
how do we know that the non-leading
eigenva
vector value is bounded by the square
root of n
because uh we can we can subtract a
matrix of rank one
and then the entries will be centered
and for the centered uh for the center
entries will have a bound square root of
them on the norm so on
all eigen values
uh what's what was the second question
how do you know that there is at least
two domains
again it's a non-leading eigenvalue
you so the eigenvector should be
orthogonal
to the leading one and the leading one
is almost
one one one one vector
so the sum of the coordinates
should be about zero okay
okay
and now if you look at these two numbers
cn
and and to the negative one half
we we see that i have a lot of room
and this room means that in all this
story i can relax the condition that p
is constant
mark uh when they prove this theorem the
no gaps they record
the localization result wasn't out there
yet right
right did it make things much more
complicated
just out of curiosity ah not much more
but more
complicated they had an er zest notion
for
it
okay okay okay
and the same idea allows
to show that if p is large enough
then with high probability any vertex
in the positive modal domain
is connected to many vertices in the
negative nodal domain
and the similar thing happens for
negative normal domain
so everything is connected the ra
there is no non-trivial geography
there are no heights and
informally a gene p graph graph
is a swamp so the whole program
and this point falls apart
then there is another natural question
let's take an
eigenvector let's take
its positive and negative normal domain
we know that there are one of each
and if the things are fair they should
have
approximately or almost exactly the same
size
so
is it true that the size of the positive
normal domain
is more or less the same as for the
negative one
and we know the tool which
is used for for this purpose it's the
localization
but if you try to use it it doesn't work
let's imagine the situation that
an eigenvector looks like this we have
two thirds coordinate
two third and coordinates which are
positive
and one third coordinates which are
negative
and the size of the coordinates is over
about
one over square root of n first
this vector is orthogonal to the vector
1 1
1 1 which means that it may be
a candidate for an eigenvector
second it has no large coordinates
it doesn't violate the l-infinity
localization
and it doesn't violate the no gaps
localization either
because it has no small coordinates
so the localization is not enough
nevertheless one can prove that
for any non-leading eigenvector
the nodal domains have the same size
and there are two theorems
referring to intermediate eigenvectors
and to extreme eigenvectors the
intermediate ones
are called bulk the extreme
are called edge so let me start with the
bulk one
here i suppose that p is
say of the power type
and i consider eigenvector
which is uh not the first one
far from the first one and far from the
last one
but how far is in my hands
and then yeah
the nodal domains cannot be larger than
one half plus epsilon and
with any significant probability
the second theorem refers to the edge
case
and the formulation is almost exactly
the same
it's the same up to small details first
here i'll assume
more about the probability it's a
constant
and then i'm dealing with an edge so
that i can vector corresponds to the
eigenvalue which is either one of the
first ones
except the leading or one of the last
ones
and then the size of the nodal domain
cannot exceed one half plus something
smaller times
n with any significant probability
these theorems look like twins the proof
has absolutely nothing in common
and let me talk now about the proof of
the bulk theorem because
it uh uh
it's a little more unorthodox
from the random matrix point of view
okay so first a very high
level idea we want to show that the
nodal domains are bound
are balanced they have the same number
of vertices
which means that if we sum the signs
of the eigenvector we should get
something much smaller than
m this can be derived
from marco's inequality
if i square this random variable and
take the expectation
this should be much smaller than n
squared
now i can develop this square
and what i will need is
the expectation of the sign of the
product of two coordinates
is all small of one a sine is not a good
function it's not even continuous
so instead of the sine we can try to
approximate it's
it by an odd polynomial
prove the same equality that is so small
of 1 for the expectation of an
odd polynomial and then
estimate the the error which we
make by replacing the polynomial by a
sign
unfortunately it wouldn't work as it's
written
because the error is too large
but uh this is more or less what we are
going to do
and indeed our proof uh goes in two
steps
first we are going to show that the
expectation
of the polynomial
is small and then we will
approximate why polynomial
there is already statement
for polynomials and random matrix theory
and if you take an eigenvector
of a gmp graph and
project it onto a deterministic
direction
then this projection is more or less
normal
and formally if you take a polynomial
of the squared projection
its expectation is
almost the same as the expectation of a
square of a normal random standard
normal random variable
very good we have an information about
polynomials
and now what we need we need
an odd polynomial remember we
approximate a sine
and we need that
with high probability this polynomial
is small for most pairs
of coordinates
so let's compare what we have
what we need there are two problems
the main problem is
that it's not just an arbitrary
polynomial
is the polynomial of a square and a
polynomial of a square is hardly
an odd polynomial
and a secondary problem this is not
any projection it's a projection
orthogonal to the vector 1 1 1 1
which plays a special row
for graphs because the adjacency matrix
uh
has no zero expectation
and this is the eigenvector of the
matrix of expectations
okay so
now we have this
condition and we
need an odd polynomial of the product
so we start with the polynomial of one
variable we go
down to the polynomial of of one
variable
but on the way we have to pass through
the polynomials of four variables
and then of two variables and finally
we'll go
to one variable so
the first step is getting rid of this
q
let's take a vector q with a small
support the support
less or equal than four of course a
general
vector like this is not orthogonal to
one one one one
but it is almost orthogonal
and we can use this fact
to approximate to make an approximation
and it turns out that we can extend
a basic wallet inequality for the
vectors almost orthogonal to you
of course four has no specific role here
but
it is uh four or four variables will be
needed
for our argument
now we have it for adq
and we interpolate over
several values of this q and this allows
us to prove
the same statement for
any polynomial of four variables
good for any even polynomial
now let's uh consider an even
polynomial of two variables
and i want a stronger statement about
this even polynomial of two variables
let's introduce the deviation
of the value of this polynomial on the
coordinates
and on two independent gaussian random
variables
this is a random variable and it turns
out that
if i take distinct indices i
j k l these two
random variables will be almost
uncorrelated
they cannot be independent because they
come from the same eigenvector but
they're
almost uncorrelated and the reason is
that when you develop
this expectation each
f depends on two variables you get a
polynomial of four variables you can use
what you already know
okay and this
lack of correlation allows to show that
with high probability
for most pairs i j
the deviation of f
from the expected
value of the polynomial on the pair of
independent gauss and variables is
small so this is where non-trivial step
the third step is trivial
let's finally pass to one
variable
and uh
let's take another polynomial as we
always wanted
and the polynomial will be just
uh the polynomial of two variables will
be just
f of the product
if f small is odd
f capital is of course even
we are in the previous setup and
moreover
the expectation of this new polynomial
and l of two variables
will be zero because f small result and
then
we got that with high probability
most of the pairs
have the value of this polynomial on the
product of the coordinates
is small or we can
pass to the expectation but this time
we take a different expectation
so with high probability was over the
matrices now we condition
on the matrix or on the graph
and take expectation with respect to
random pair of coordinates
and we know that this expectation
is going to be small
we want to infer that the same
expectation for the sign
is small so we are done with the
preprocessing step
and with the evaluating of the
polynomial
now the second step is approximation
and of course if we know the statement
for polynomials
we approximate the sign by a polynomial
and use the fact for the polynomial
good but we cannot approximate a sine
by a polynomial everywhere there is one
region
where this approximation goes bad
it's a region around zero but this is
a relatively harmless region we have no
gaps the localization
which tells us that only a few
coordinates
are here so we can't say
that the contribution of these
coordinates will be small
and then we have another region where
the approximation doesn't
work it's the large coordinates is
these two regions
and the intermediate
area where the most coordinates leave
this here we use uniform approximation
and just replace the value of the
polynomial by the value of the sign
so we have to take care only
of these tails
and
we have to count the contribution of the
coordinates but
we can replace it with the l2 bound
with respect to the distribution of the
product of independent
gaussian random variables again
recycling this argument
about the evaluation of
approximate normality
okay but if we look at these
requirements they
are conflicting we have to
make the contribution of large
coordinates small
to make the error small and this is very
easy to do we know that the coordinates
over a square root of n so if i push
this r
capital to the right the contribution
will be smaller and smaller
but if i do it and i push r to the right
i have to keep the uniform
approximation of this intermediate
interval
and for this i need a high power
approximating
a higher power of approximating
polynomial
but this higher power means faster
increase
of the tail and it means that
this puts more weight on
the large coordinates
so the main part of the argument is
to see how to satisfy both
conditions at the same time but if you
look at this
at this moment we leave the realm of
probability
and the problem becomes purely analytic
we have a function sine
we have to and we have to approximate it
in two norms
and the norms are given this measure mu
is a fixed measure first of all
let's get rid of the this small interval
we can convolve uh the sign
with the nice function so that
the convolution will be smooth
and we will not commit a large error
here
because of no gaps to localization so
instead of approximating sign
we will approximate the smooth
sign how do we approximate it
we need uniform approximation on complex
sets
and at the same time we need l2
approximation with respect to the given
measurement so we have two neuron spaces
instead of then we would take one norm
space of course
and try to approximate in this known
space the most
the right way is to take the sum of the
l infinity and l to norm
this captures all this information but
it is not very helpful
because you don't know what to do with
this norm
instead we'll take the sobolev space
norm
with one derivative l2 type sublive
space norm but not the standard sublime
space
will take it with different measures at
the one
and after two and these measures
are in our hands we can choose them
as we wish
so how to and then
we introduce the space and we will prove
that
all polynomials approximate
the smooth sign in this space
so what do we need from these mirrors
the first thing is that
we want to control the l2 norm
and this means that the measure nu1
should be greater than the measurement
this already shows that
at a once right at a one
can not be a nice measure the measure mu
has a singularity at zero at a one
would inherit it
then the second term
the circular term will be used
to derive uniform approximation
and so we will uh
try to choose cata 2 to get a nice
control
on the on the infinity norm
this is available through builder
okay and now
we need to choose this data one and
after two
to guarantee that the approximation is
possible
and here we have all the tools of
analysis available to us
first this is a hilbert space
and so if the approximation is
impossible
we can find an orthogonal
uh uh to the
space of odd uh
polynomials which has a nonzero inner
product with our f
and then we can play with the fourier
transform
and this indeed yields the result
okay
i'm not going to talk about uh
the proof of the edge case
uh this is uh more technical than that
but
let me finish with
a few open problems mark
yes uh didn't the argument you just show
basically prove that the empirical
distribution
of the eigenvector is approximately
symmetric
around zero because instead of taking
sine you could do
you know any like any indicator of
interval minus its negative and it would
work
more or less the same no yes i think so
i just didn't know that this is an
interesting question
i mean it's stronger than just yes yes
you're right okay
actually instead of this smooth sign you
can put
many things there not necessarily
indicators
they should be of a moderate growth
okay so let me
at the end discussed a few open problems
first i i already said that we can relax
the condition that p is constant and
take a little mascara theorem
but how much can we relax it
the random matrix part seems to go
through
for all on and on piece
but we started with this trivial step
that the giant set is relatively small
and all we got was
this estimate and this estimate is very
close
if p is small
so we don't have a start
and indeed we don't have a firm results
but numerical experiments done
independently by
han juan and ronaldo
show that if p is small and
the eigenvalue is at the negative edge
then there are multiple
one vertex nodal domains
why uh negative edge
this is because for this case
it's feasible to run a simulation
probably it's for all negative lambdas
and of course it's hard from the
simulation
to say where this phase transition was
but roman conjecture that
it is of the logarithmic
order uh the edge of connectivity
is log n over uh the phase transition
for connectivity is on the level log
n over n and here is another phase
transition
on the level c log n over n
at this conjecture phase transition with
c greater than one
the second question is the geography of
normal domains
and i said that one can prove that it is
trivial if he is large enough but
as he becomes smaller again
the only thing we we know because of
hans experiments is
that at the certain level this breaks
down
and a non-trivial geography appears
the positive and negative normal domains
acquire depth again where
this phase transition lies we do not
know
but in both cases these are
sparse random graphs but there are
problems
also for dense random graphs
and this is a problem posed by nothing
lineal
let's consider any graph a deterministic
graph
and its partition is called inner
if any vertex in one part
has more neighbors in the same part than
in the other one and outer
if the opposite happens any vertex in u
has more neighbors in w
than in u itself it's not
obvious that such partitions exist
actually the fact that the outer
partitions exist
is not an easy but a homework exercise
for inner partition the picture is much
harder
and the conjecture of lineal
suggests how how to find these
partitions in particular algorithmically
if we take a positive eigenvalue
and unleading positive eigenvalue then
the partition into null the means
is an inner partition with high
probability
and the
if it is negative then
the partition will be an outer one with
high probability
okay i
i finished a little quicker than i
planned but let me stop here
thanks mark uh are there questions or
comments
um i i i just
i i wanted to ask two things first of
all when you switched to the proof
after you had stated your theorems with
han i just
didn't fully understand why is it enough
to prove that the summer coordinates
of uh the non-native nugget vector is
small
in order to show that there is two
domains it's a stupid question i'm sure
but
i just wanted to give your son the signs
what you do
for the positive total domain for each
vertex you
add one
so you count the the cardinality of
positive vertices for negative
uh normal domain you subtract one
because the sign is negative one so you
subtract the cardinality
of the negative normal domain and this
difference
should be much smaller than n
okay and i was curious actually
for deterministic graphs is there an
analog of quran
theorem obviously it can it cannot hold
in full generality because you just
showed something completely different
but
like under some conditions uh no
uh yes and no first there is a precise
analog
of quran's theorem the number of normal
domains
of k eigenvalue does not exceed
k but quran so the answer is yes but the
answer is no
quran's theorem gives only an upper
bound
uh it doesn't provide a lower bound so
it is as most k
but as we saw it can be two
yeah and is there a situation where
deterministic graphene is also bounded
from below the cave and it's like
no random in some cases you know yes
triangulation
so there is no theorem that says if a
graph is like that like that like that
i don't know maybe embeddable into a
manifold but no
and it would be interesting to know
what property is behind it
there are other questions
has this been studied for other models
of random graphs like for example ones
with more sort of
geometric
so far not but this would make sense
and
[Music]
here i i'm going to press pass on uh
rondan since it's territory
uh there are uh
work of el don ras and shram
on brace paradox
that adding a random
edge to the graph
uh can decrease the spectral gap
and this is you know they proved that it
is
true with a constant probability
for a gmp graph
this is rather counterintuitive because
we are going towards
the complete graph and the complete
graph has the largest
uh spectral gap
and the reason for this was
a brace paradox that in civil
engineering
that if you
add a highway to an existing highways
system
you uh can increase the congestion
find chang suggested to model this
situation
by saying that a high
highway network is a graph a gmp graph
and the conjecture in a congestion is
measured by
the spectral gap the second thing is
very reasonable because the spectral gap
is responsible for uh
for mixing of a random walk for
relaxation or for
more precisely but
to model the highway
system by gnp graph is a little
farfetched
so it would make sense
to consider other so to say
double quotes more realistic graphs
but so far the only results exist for
gnp
because of independence
i'm a bit curious what drives you to
found the first moment by the
second it just doesn't happen every day
because the quantity is not positive
the first
is this sound somewhere else you have to
bound
the absolute value of the expectation
uh-huh i see it's because of the
absolute value you don't know how to
deal with it so you move to square is
that the reason
yes as soon as you put the absolute
value inside the expectation you get the
absolute value of a sign
and this is not very helpful okay
additional questions or comments
uh mark about linear's conjecture
even if you relax like the definition a
little bit and you require like the
inner and outer conditions to
not hold for any vertex but for like
one minus little of one proportion of
vertices
i think probably even then it's kind of
like
impossible to find such sets unless you
look
at like nodal domains right i don't know
i mean it's kind of plausible that maybe
the only sets okay i don't know
i mean maybe not it's just
it seems to me like too strong a
condition that any vertex
even if you don't require all of them
but almost all of them it's
already a very strong condition and
that's probably satisfied by no load of
domains
okay maybe i don't know how to show it
but by the way for the outer normal
domain
sorry for an outer partition the
existence
is just pigeonholing
ah okay i see inner is hard
right and a second question do you think
there is any hope to use this
idea with the polynomials to show like a
central limit theorem for the
empirical distribution
uh the central limit stuff is uh
actually done and this is a different
story because for the central limit
you take the limit you die i know right
yeah yeah and uh quantitative estimates
and there are very strong much stronger
results in this direction so called
quantum unique ergodicity of uh
uh
okay
okay more questions or comments
not uh let's thank mark again
and that's it for today
see you next week